こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
あの上手く言えないんですけども、あのすごい困っていることがあります。
まず見ていただきたいんですけども、
これが始まったのが・・・どんぐらいだっけな？
ちょっとたなっちに電話してみよ
もしもしたなっち？
あのさー
俺さー
指にさー
変なデキモノできてんじゃん
これいつからだっけ？
なんかもうたぶん・・・3ヶ月前くらいだよね
これなんなんかねこれ
♪ﾎﾟﾛﾘｯ（電話を切る音）
というわけで今言った通りでございます。
なんか指に変なできものみたいなのができてて、
もう3ヶ月くらいずーっと取れずに残ってます。
見ます？？
別になんかそんなグロイものって認識はないんですけどね。
こっから見ると分かりやすいんすよ。もう、
ポツーンってなっててここが
ほら・・・これね？これね？
結構デカいんですよ。
今のじゃちょっと分かりにくいと思うからスマホで撮っとくね
（シャッターを切る効果音）
いや、これ何なんすかね？
指に硬いものができたなと思ってて、
→って思ってたんですけど、
どんどんなんか指の表面にこうやってどんどん出てきて、
で1ヶ月前くらいに完全になんかもうモノになっちゃって・・・
気づいたらもう、こんなのになってました
なんかイボとか・・・
な　ん　な　の　！　？　！　？
わっかんないんですよ、なんか
その取れる気配でもないし
水ぶくれって言われるんですけど水って硬さでもないんですよ
結構ガンガンに硬くて
で痛みもないんですよ、
取ろうと思えば取れるみたいな感じです
これっすよこれ・・・
えでもなんかもう→
ほら取れるよこれ悪いけど
なんか何回か取ろうと試したんですけども、硬すぎて
なんかちょっと良くないなと思って我慢してたんですけど・・・
そして動画も回っている・・・
ちょっと取ってみます
えぇ待って痛いぃ痛い痛いｲﾀｲ・・・
皮膚が結局・・・皮膚とれるんだよね
え、取れね！？
とるっ・・・
いやームリだ取れねぇなぁ
ごめん・・・無理だった
えぇすげぇこわいよー！！！
こーゆーの出たら怖いんですよ～！！
てかまず、なんなのこれは？
オレわかんないもん！
水ぶくれとかなら分かります、なんか火傷とかしたらプクッてなるの分かりますし
水ぶくれっていう硬さでもないし、
まってなんか→
ちょっと今日はこの原因を突き止めたい！
けっこう困ってます、硬いんすよ。
（コンコンと机を叩く音）
ちょっとネットで調べます。
『指　硬い』・・・
えっ？
「皮膚が硬くなるのは【表皮症】の症状」
オレ皮膚硬くなんのかな・・・
なんか悪い病気の前ぶれとかの可能性もあるんで
ちょっと結構ビビってます。
手に、皮膚のできもの・・・
ふくらんでいたら・・・
あっ？
「ふくらんでいるというのは腫瘍の大きな特徴のひとつです」
ﾋｭﾝｯ（効果音）
怖くなって怖くなってきた助けて助けて・・・
え、病院行こっかな？
「指のしこり、できもの」
それだ多分！
指のしこりとできものだこれ
あっ、あっこれかな？
たっ・・・
タコなの・・・えっタコじゃないんだよなぁ
「皮膚の角質の増殖が起こり皮膚の表面が厚く硬くなった症状、いわゆる【タコ】のこと」
タコじゃないんだよ、そんなペンダコみたいな感じでもないんですよね
明らかに異常に飛び出てるんすよね
「毛穴の根元に細菌が感染した状態」
いやそんな、毛穴があるような場所でもないん・・・
指の手のひらに無いはずだとは思うんですけどね
え、分かんない・・・
え、えぇ待ってこれかも
「へバーデン結節」
「手、指の第一関節・・・
の指の一番先端の」・・・
やばい！マジじゃん！！
「関節が腫れたり曲がったりして時には痛みを伴う状態」
あ大丈夫ですね。
痛みはまったくないです
水疱瘡（みずぼうそう）
違う。水疱瘡はもう僕なったはずです
なにわっかんない、わかんない・・・
指にできものができる病気みたいなのって結構多いみたいですね
あれなんか画像で・・・
たくさんあるな
うあぁグロいグロいグロい！！！
あ゛ぁーグロい！！！
グロい嫌だぁあうわぁ・・・
いまなんかGoogleの画像で指のできもの調べてたら
なんかグロい血だらけのばっかでもう・・・無理
あ゛ぁあー
早く病院行けよぉ・・・
イボなのかな・・・
イボ？イボなのかな
えっ、えっ待って待って待って待って待って！！！
ヤバい！ヤバい！！今の
調べたんですけど
「むやみに触るのはNG」
「気になってむやみに触ったり切り取ろうとしたりするとさらにイボが広がってしまうことがあるため→
できるだけ触らずに」・・・
だってこんな場所って日常的に使う場所じゃん！！
日常的に使うところを触るなっていうのは流石に難しいですよ先生・・・
ただもう本当に唯一の救いなのが、痛くないんで
特にあっても問題はないんですよね。
ただ油断ならんのですよ・・・
結局みなさん病気っていうのは早期発見が大事なんで
いやホントに誰か・・・
助けてください。
そもそもこれがイボなのかどうかも僕ちょっと今調べた感覚でよくわかんなかったんで
なんか詳しい方いたら教えてください・・・
ホントに心配です
取っていいのか取って悪いのかもよくわかんないし
ただひとつわかるのが本当にね、
（強調）け　っ　こ　う目立つんすよね指でも
いやーマジでわからんな
ちょっとよく分かんないんですけど
えぇやだよ変な病気だったらや゛だぁ゛！！！（泣）
食生活悪かったら゛ごめん゛なさ゛い゛！！
もうラーメン食べませ゛ん！！
いや食べますけど（素）
ｺﾞｻﾞｲﾏｽｩ...（再び泣く）
ちょっとよくわかんないんでほんとコメント欄とか見ていろいろ考えて
病院に行こうか決めます
♫～エンディング